I think it's so unusual how you got the
job on Saturday Night Live well I was an
assistant editor on Iron Chef America
and that was when I got the phone call
yeah I was getting yelled at by my
editor and I got a phone call saying hi
is Lindsay shook us from SNL Lorne
Michaels would like more and would like
to meet you but doesn't even get more
bizarre than that that movie wasn't it
wasn't it like so you're this guy you're
an assistant editor not a cooking show
wood iron chef well and you are doing
some improv on the side yeah right
you're just kind of doing your thing and
you know you weren't even you weren't
imagining being on Saturday night wasn't
a big dream of yours now I was like
going to Mars or something it was like I
don't ever happen you know and then some
actress went down to wherever it is you
do improv and she went there to see her
brother-in-law yeah Megan Mullally from
from Will and Grace and her husband is
Nick Offerman from Parks and Rec right
his brother Matt Offerman and I were in
a group together and so they went to go
see their you know his brothers show she
sees you and she calls NBC and since you
got to come see this guy yeah so she saw
that show she talked to Lauren I went
out met morn and I just thought well
this is a story I'll tell my grandkids I
wasn't I met Lauren like I didn't think
I honest-to-god didn't think anything
was gonna come out of it right and I met
him and then he said I want to see the
show that she saw right and and then he
came to LA to see that show and then he
knew the people in the audience were all
our friends so we blew the roof off the
place but he kind of smelled a rat give
me a break did you like that audience
with your friends on but absolutely
Lorne Michaels was come absolutely I was
like you guys have to go apeshit
yeah we'd even do anything like the
house lights went down if you were crazy
and ripping the seats out and he was
like oh I see what you guys are doing
this is [ __ ] you guys gotta come out
to New York so he flew us out to New
York when no one knew us and and and it
was all the front row is like you know
Tina Fey Amy Poehler oh my god it was
was that intimidating unbelievably
intimidating you know what was in that
audience I didn't was Bobby Moynihan
just went he's you know all these people
from New York were like they flew these
guys in and there must be phenomenal who
is this yeah what was that show that you
did that caught Lauren's attention and
and Megan's attention well I'll tell you
what I make and Asajj a normal show that
we did that didn't have anything really
that I do on the show but once I found
out that Lauren was coming
Naomi Odenkirk who I kind of knew
peripherally who's now my manager she
said well you know do you do impressions
do you know do any characters and I was
like not know I don't don't know I don't
do so many impressions and character you
know I found out I kind of had a
facility for that for the show I didn't
really think about it in those terms so
I said well let me work on some stuff
and my and those guys those three guys
said you know what why don't we do a
sketch but in it will kind of be an SNL
audition so I didn't if any vedecci the
Italian guy
[Music]
doing a bad open mic night sketch where
they were in the audience heckling me
and I was doing impressions and stuff
again more and be much smarter than any
of us saw exactly what we were trying to
do right it was like I really liked the
audition sketch you have never done
stand-up comedy mm-hmm and you're kind
of afraid of it or intimidated by or
just yeah all those things it was kind
of like I don't know I don't know if I
really want to do this every try they
for my audition I would go up and do
stand-up stuff to get ready for my
audition for what you do with your
audition for us I know did you do a
whole bunch of impressions I did Vinny
vedecci the Italian guy doing
impressions did you do your Alan Alda
because now I figured that out later
that spot on that dinosaur comes out and
it takes me that is just terrific you
have to work into it or yeah I have to
kind of work into it those are always
and work into something like that I
watch him from crimes and misdemeanors
and I'm doing the thing about you know
if it bends you know that thing you know
if the bends it's funny if it breaks
it's not funny there's a whole scene and
crimes and misdemeanors but it was nice
because I talked to like Darrell Hammond
when I started the show and Dana Carvey
you know when he came to the show and
asked them about impressions and it made
me feel better that they were kind of
the same way they're like oh yeah it's
hard to kind of just go right into it
you got it kind of were you a fan of
Saturday Night Live growing up oh yeah
you were huge so so you're sort of a
student of the thing but you never said
to yourself hey one day maybe I'll be on
that now I grew up in Tulsa Oklahoma it
was just like just know like the fact
that I moved to LA well either that was
like news in the paper you know